what would happen if we just legalized
all drugs that was the topic of our
recent conversation with Ethan nadelman
founder and former head of the drug
policy Alliance and host of this
psychoactive podcast if you think about
it we were the evil empire of the global
war on drugs for the last hundred years
and yet nonetheless the same country
which had the most oppressive drug
policy of any Democratic Society and
criminal justice policy in the history
of democratic societies which has been
the global champion and proselytizer of
the War on Drugs we nonetheless became
the world leader when it came to legally
regulating cannabis that's how nadelman
gave me hope that after more than half a
century of this disastrous War on Drugs
America can turn things around and lead
the world in a different direction
there's a lot of momentum in our favor
with cannabis legalization of some sort
in the majority of states the burgeoning
Psychedelic legalization movement and
increasingly wide acceptance of harm
reduction strategy energies like needle
exchanges safe consumption sites and
all-out Drug decriminalization basically
boils down to we don't want to put
anybody behind bars for simple
possession of small amounts of drugs for
their own use if they're not hurting
anybody else that's the essence of
decriminalization but the process hasn't
always been smooth after organ
decriminalized all drugs in 2021
overdoses went up very few users sought
treatment and those who did often had
trouble getting it according to
reporting from The Oregonian critics
like Mike Marshall of the treatment
advocacy Coalition organ recovers say
the measure should have established a
robust Network for people addicted to
drugs before decriminalizing I'm worried
about the person living on the street in
a tent right outside this window whose
smoke and meth all day long and they're
destroying their system but nadelman
says imperfect rollouts are never an
excuse to maintain an unacceptable
status quo fewer people going to jail
crime not going up as a result of the
initiative and more people getting help
is it going to be perfect no is it a
major transformation that sets a model
for other states in the country in the
same way that the European countries
provided a model for what Oregon did yes
so what are the big lessons from the way
drug decriminalization has actually been
implemented in the real world
when Portugal faced an overdose crisis
it decriminalized all drugs in 2000
which led to dramatic Falls and
overdoses imprisonment and HIV
infections but Portugal's
decriminalization isn't the same as
legalization
drug dealers still get arrested keeping
a black market alive and users can get
citations to appear in front of a panel
comprised of a lawyer social worker and
a psychologist who can recommend and
even compel treatment or other
interventions
in Oregon police can hand out tickets
for public drug use which can be
dismissed with a consultation call to a
drug abuse hotline but there's also no
penalty for simply ignoring the ticket
the lack of accountability built into
the measure that would be my concern is
that we see a bunch of money in the
system that isn't having an effect did
Oregon air in taking a lighter touch
approach than Portugal nadelman says
Portugal system is widely misunderstood
they're not about sending people to
treatment I mean what they're basically
doing is figuring out how do we need how
can we help this person does this person
need to go to an employment counselor
does this person you know they would say
a lot of a lot of people who are
committed drug juicers if you say go to
treatment they don't want to go to
treatment but if the person on a
commission goes Hey listen I see those
marks on your arms it looks like they're
getting some abscesses some infections
there why don't you go and see a doctor
to have that your abscess is checked out
and they've and then a drug user will go
to a doctor rather than a treatment
person and then the commission person
calls the doctor and says by the way
here's what's going on when you look at
the guy you know it's a more subtle
approach it's focused not on achieving
abstinence and more and helping people
get their lives together be less of a
burden and Troublesome to the community
and get their stuff together creating a
greater burden on communities is exactly
what opponents of drug liberalization
fear most Americans don't want to see
tent encampments like those that have
overtaken La San Francisco and Portland
and those of us who want to end drug
prohibition once and for all have to
make the case for why that won't happen
nadelman says that opponents of harm
reduction strategies like San Francisco
author Michael schellenberger who
opposes safe consumption sites are
missing the fact that such approaches
can help move the disorder on the
streets to safer more controlled indoor
settings but only if Mayors and DA's
also enforce basic quality of life loss
nadelman points to the Frankfurt model
which was developed 30 years ago when
the German city was having a major
problem with open-air drug dealing and
using in public parks so the mayor set
up a Monday morning group with the head
of police prosecution Health Services
Social Services Housing Services and a
few of the other top people and at that
meeting it was like okay what's the
focus here and the police would say well
we're thinking of having a little
Crackdown of this neighborhood there you
know and then the Clinton may would say
well so what are we going to do with the
people that you're picking up and then
it would be well can housing take them
can this take them it was a coordinated
policy of the sort that for example
mayor London breed in San Francisco has
totally abdicated has totally failed the
key to dealing with open-air drug
markets is not getting rid of drug use
because you can't do that or you can
only try to reduce it through other
programs the key is pushing that stuff
indoors in ways that don't harm the rest
of the community more than a hundred six
thousand Americans died from an opioid
related overdose in 2021 according to
the CDC the vast majority of those were
from synthetic opioids like fentanyl
represented by the Gray Line in this
graph we know that prohibition create
created Black Market fentanyl which is
killing Americans and fueling violent
cartels harm reduction approaches like
needle exchanges and safe consumption
sites are proven to save lives under
these conditions but maybe now is the
time for more drastic measures
Portugal took the radical step of total
decriminalization in 2000 to deal with
its problem maybe America needs to take
things even further and not only
decriminalize but allow sales and defeat
the deadly Black Market once and for all
what if we treated all drugs the way we
treat alcohol
what if the world's number one drug
Warrior became the world's leading
legalizer if you're going to legalize
cocaine are you going to legalize it
only in a kind of cocaine cocoa tea
version which has cocaine in it are you
going to legalize the sale of 10 pure
potency powder for snorting are you
going to allow it to be sold in
injectable or smokable forms but the
stimulant drugs are the ones the cocaine
methamphetamine are the really really
tricky challenging ones drug policy is a
tricky thing in a sense gaining mass
support for legalizing cannabis are
relatively low risk drug was the easy
part and it took Decades of effort
but we don't have decades the
consequences of the drug war
incarceration Injustice a deadly Black
Market that funds Bad actors are more
pressing than ever if I took away
anything from this recent conversation
it was that political pragmatism largely
is what got the drug legalization
movement this far and it is likely that
same pragmatism upon which its future
also depends one thing I'm trying to
talk to younger activists about is one
of the things that I think made us
successful with drug policy reform was
our communication our realization that
we don't win unless we persuade the
ordinary American middle of the road
parent that what we're saying about
marijuana or other drugs is more
persuasive than what the other side is
that means speaking a language it means
not using Progressive speaking that
means not using not just academic
language but Lefty type language you
know it means not putting your identity
first you put the message for verse
right these are all sorts of things that
seem to have been lost or dismissed
among a younger generation of activists
thanks for checking out that recap of
the conversation nicolespie and I had
with Ethan nadelman about the path to
decriminalizing and maybe even
legalizing all drugs you can watch a
clip from that conversation here or the
full two-hour discussion over here